everyone so
i'm glad to be here representing our
research to you
and my name is claudia aguilar i'm an
associate professor in the department of
biological sciences
at purdue university
and our lab is interested in
in
different things in particular we are
interested in vesicle trafficking
in general and in particular in
endocytosis
specifically we are very interested in
how receptors interact with ligands and
the ligands then turn
to activate the receptors by
dynamization for example in the case of
preceptor tyrosine kinases
and that is followed by um recruitment
of uh different
elements of the interstellar machinery
some of them are required for
uh post-translational modification of
receptors such as human continuation
phosphorylation and others are required
for the assembly of the endocytic
machinery for example in this case i'm
showing you
um adapter complexes
like ap2 and epsilon that are capable of
recognizing the receptor that need to be
internalized and at the same time they
adapt the membrane and the receptors to
the clattering code
so um
our lab i've been very interested not
only in the process of endocytosis but
also on how these
events
affect the signaling processes so
signaling for example here in blue with
the the blue
lightning bolt pointing at you the
signaling that comes from the receptor
as a consequence of ligand binding
and activation but also
through other signaling events such as
uh one that we discovered in the lab
some time ago it has to do with certain
adapters like epson um
interacting and affecting the activity
of raw gtps regulators then affecting
other signaling pathways very important
for
cell polarity migration and whatnot
so these complexes are the focus of our
research
and and this research focus is um
mostly towards a basic applications but
also translational applications with a
particular
interest in cancer and developmental
diseases
so
in today's talk i'm going to describe
one of the lines of research that we
carry on with
cancer
in our aim and um and it involves the
use of the ligand receptor interaction
for
therapeutic purposes
so
in particularly we are interested in in
strategies
that
change modulate take advantage of
endocytosis
for the development of a anti-bladder
cancer agent so this is our major focus
although we are now branching to other
types of cancers as well
um
so
let me tell you a little bit about
bladder cancer
so bladder cancer is the fourth among
men and women among women so you have an
idea of what is the impact
that it has
the first line of defense the therapy is
the tumor sections of course and here
we're talking about superficial bladder
cancer if it's invasive
the
the therapeutic approach of choice is
the removal of the blood
so
tumor resection and this is a process
that is done via the urethra so so the
the
tumor is targeted
so
endoscopic technique and is removed
and
following um
this
this process after six and 24 hours
there is an adjuvant therapy that is
added so there is an immuno or chemo
therapeutic agent that is added again
through the urethra into the lumen of
the
this is not
a
treatment that occurs via the blood
stream it's via the urethra into the
lumen of the bladder and these agents
are applied so that it can eliminate
leftover cells
and
and assure the complete elimination of
the tumor
so
um
unfortunately these
therapies are of low efficiency so far
they are also
with a certain level of toxicity and
side effects and this is due mostly
because their targeting
is limited they are also able to hit
normal cells
um
unfortunately patients also develop
a
high resistance due to this treatment so
after a while these treatments are no
longer
affected so that
pose a problem
in addition some of these agents
particularly bcg the bacillus government
uranus will refer to it in one second um
are in low availability nowadays somehow
um
there's been a
worldwide short shortage of pcg
so some people scrambling looking for
novel therapeutic approaches
and i forgot to mention but these
therapies usually involve
sessions very long two or three hours
long
because the toxicity and side effects
patients develop sensitivity
inflammation and whatnot so make it very
difficult for them to go through such
long sessions so that's another problem
with the current available therapies
this scenario which is less than optimal
it leads to uh
the current status of the
of the bladder cancer which is to deal
with a 70 percent recurrence post
surgery so so this is huge that seven
out of ten patients may return
to the to the office to the clinic with
one or more tumors so and they need to
start all over again the process so as
you can imagine this is this is a
very
a complex scenario
it's very taxing for the patient
but also for the u.s healthcare system
it's considered that the cost is about
above
four billion dollars in yearly
so definitely there is a need for a more
efficient a lower toxicity approach
against these disease
let me get into more details about these
tumors so these tumors arise from the
epithelial layer of the bladder
so here you can see in the
representation of the bladder on top
and then a section enlarged of the aptly
that covers the bladder
the bladder low maintenance where the
urine is
accumulated
so the the lumen the epithelia that
makes the
the
the lining of the bladder is made of
different
layers in which the top layer is the
more differentiated cells they are
called umbrella cells
and these cells secrete
a glycosaminoglycan layer that is built
on top of them
and
they establish the tight junctions as
well and they secrete some
proteins called europlankins that form
sort of a
semicrystalline armor that protects the
cell so all these is to indeed to
protect the cells the epithelium from
the harsh environment of the urine in
the in the bladder lumen
when a tumor arises
yeah that's what you can see here in the
in the blue rectangle so the cells the
normal cells the normal muscles
protected by tight junctions europe
plugins and the calculator but when a
tumor arises is less differentiated it
produces very little or none of the gag
layer
multi multi-junctions europlankins are
not secreted they are accumulating
inside the cells now
and so they protrude towards the bladder
so this is a situation in which the bad
guys the tumors are exposed to the lumen
when the normal cells are protected by
the gag layer and the other elements i
described
so it's one of those scenarios in which
we could
if we add the therapeutic in the lumen
of the blood via the urethra to be able
to touch to attack
the tumor cells without affecting the
normal cells
of course the pelvics can diffuse
in
towards the the normal cells that they
during the normal cells and geogenesis
also can be involved in the distribution
of the representations in the
environment of the normal cells and if
the therapy is effective um
so it may eventually reduce the tumor
mass gaining access to normal cells so
so we really need not only very
efficient but some counselling
agents
so
um
years ago we developed a strategy that
we call the microclustering strategy to
deliver agents into tumor cells
um
why we need such strategy
as i mentioned to you so the tumors are
facing and are protruding towards the
lumen they're facing the urine
so under these conditions
the um the actual uptake the endocytic
event
is really poor the cells are
very low and slow for endocytosis each
time that there is an
in
an involvement of main energy producing
the psychosis there is an income also an
uptake of urine so so there is a there
is a slow
rate of endocytosis for the cell so so
we devise this strategy to accelerate
the process
and indeed this strategy was um
inspired
by um
the
mode of action of the basilisk media you
remember i referred to it is the therapy
and the adjuvant therapy of choice in
bladder cancer here is represented by
this little
green oval sticking to the tumor cells i
hope you can see
so this bacterium is able to interact
with the
fibronectin integrin complexes
on the tumor cells
and he produces some sort of a
clustering
because it's multiviolent it contains
many of these pyronectin attachment
proteins on the surface
that microcluster these receptors and
somehow the cell interprets that as a
sign for endocytosis
so in the lab
we
produce in collaboration with tim
bradley
an expert in bladder cancer and prostate
cancer
a recombinant recombinant form of the
fibronectin attachment product in the
vasilos carnegalene bcg
his tag and we demonstrated that this
protein actually is a truncation of the
processes containing the
fibronectin binding sites of this
problem
could be used for the generation of
strategies for delivery of the periods
so
what we demonstrated is that if we use
for example a polyclonal antibody
against fat
we could
induce the endocytosis of this age of
this program
and this was because the multiple
antibodies will bind in to different
epitopes of fat generating a network of
antibody binding on the surface that
will trust
these um
fab
fibronectin integring complexes when the
cells this sees this micro micro
clustering it
it deduces that some complexes have been
formed that need to be endocytose and
and that's the time for the recruitment
of these acidic machinery there are
other
hypotheses that we have to explain this
process which i don't have the time to
discuss but it involves bypassing
certain checkpoints
for endocytosis on the surface of the
cell
so we adapted this this uh this
technique this this process
to devise some nano liposomal agents
nanoparticles that will be decorated
with fab which was his tag and retained
in nickel npa lipids
on these
nanoparticles that were spaced in such a
way
that will emulate the distance between
the paratopes of these antibodies as is
represented in the upper
part
so
in other words these nanoliposomes
present fat in a certain density that
favors the micro cluster of fibronectin
interim complexes
so that's what you see in this cartoon
here in the bottom
um to the right you see
experiments that were done at the time
with nanoliposomes labeled with
cy5 uh with fluorescent nano liposomes
and it allows them to to detect the nano
liposomes that were taken in by mb49
cells these are mouse rather carcinoma
cells
that were expressed in graph 5 q79 l
which is a molecule a gfp fusion that
would allow us to see
endosomes like large structures so you
can see in these three panels on the
right
on the top the fluorescent nanoribosomes
in the middle the
fluorescent
gfp label in the endosomes and in the
bottom the merge image
that shows that some of these
nanoliposomes in red are located inside
of the
gfp label structures indicating that the
uptake took place
so this was a very successful approach
we published this years ago many years
ago almost 10 now
and
was the first use of this
microclustering strategy
and it has been patent
and
and it was the
this discovery of this design of the
micro cluster strategy it gave origin to
a series of generations of agents uh
which i'm gonna describe briefly now so
the first generation is the one i just
referred to
fat decorated nanoparticles that was
when we first used the micro clustering
strategy and
there is a second generation that
instead of using micro
sorry instead of using nanoparticles it
uses molecular agents it's a single
agent it's not a it's not a particle
and and those second generation agents
i'm gonna refer to in a second and then
we are working and developing a very
successful third generation as we speak
so
the second generation
were molecular agents and essentially
were
ligands to
receptors which are all
upregulated in bladder cancer
like
egf epidermal reflector for binding to
epidermal factor receptor and they were
covalently fused to
to a bacterial toxin in this case was
the anthrax toxin
and this was a project that was um
carried over by sherwin jack
which carried most of the of the
experiencing on the show but also was
taken over them by snakeheads of
romanian immediate and currently
collaborating with andres aries a new a
new student in the lab
um
we chose to use a
fusion between egf and
this bacterial toxin because epidemic
growth factor receptor is upregulated in
92 percent of liver cancers
so so it's a prime target for for
for these cells
how this is working
so
um
the fusion between egf and the toxin is
here represented by this
star i hope you can see in the
white red rectangle the different
elements represented in this cartoon
the star the red star is epidemic factor
and the blue oval is the protective
antigen subunit of the toxin so what you
can see in the upper part is a fusion
between the star and the blue
oval that interact with the epidermal
factor receptor on the plasma membrane
and as a consequence of such
the
pa the the blue oval
polychromosis microclustering
the receptors on the surface you see
that on the on the right part of this
upper part of the of the cartoon
this complex that looks like a donut is
now
competent
for binding
the signal subunit of the toxin which is
the little factor
so in this case it's a modified version
of the liquid factor to make it even
more efficient
and so this green
triangles representing the little factor
interact with the tonic and then
the micro cluster the microclustering
produces the uptake of this complex by
the way i
described before and the
low ph of the endosomal compartment
induces a conformational change in the
donut and now it becomes a pore that
goes all the way through
connecting the lumen of the enzyme with
the cytosol for the delivery of little
factor in the cytosol which it acts then
in some elongation factors blocking them
and inducing apoptosis
so um
we tried distortion
in
bladder cancer cells
in comparison with several experiments
and
i refer you to the
to a paper that i will give you a
reference for at the end of this talk
but um
we tested this agent against
different other agents that are
currently used for the treatment of
bladder cancer like gemcitabine the
mitomycin c
and what we found is that the toxin the
particular in this case we see the
viability as a function of the
concentration of the agent
what we see is that the egs toxin here
show in
close circles
is very efficient has an lc50 of less
than one nanomolar
you can see it in the
dark circles in the closed circles on
the on the left
and while um
jamsita beam it has a lc50 of 80
nanomolars
and
mitomycin c an lc50 of a thousand
nanomolars on the same cells
so as you can see there are orders of
magnitude of difference in the efficacy
of these agents
so the toxin is substantially more
efficient than any of these agents that
are currently using nuclear
but not only that a very exciting very
very
exciting in the
good news
is that this toxin has the ability that
other egf based technology has now for
example
um
the action of the toxic detoxing in her
two positive cells
so
her2 is another a member of the family
of epidemiological receptor and is known
to be counterproductive for the
functioning of ega's egf based
technologies
and the reason is because in
the presence of her2 interferes with the
normal process of endocytosis
of the epidermal factor receptor so
her2 is capable of forming
heterodimers with egfr
and and interferes with the endocytosis
the endocytosis of this heteroconflict
the heterodymer is very
slow and low
so
and that is actually one of the reasons
why um
you know her2 is such a bad prognosis
in marker because it continues to be
signaling from the plasma membrane
but also delivery of therapeutics via
egf-based technologies is impaired by
the presence of her2 because endocytosis
is impaired so we decided to see because
our agent was not using the classical
endocytic pathway of egfr whether he was
able to overcome
this blocking by country so we try
different cell lines some of them like
mb 49 here on the left of this western
broad you can see we're doing a western
block for the detection of height 2
and cubing as a loading control mb49
immuting
does not contain her2 but the human
with bladder cancer and teaching for us
and here is a control for one that
really is over expressing a lot of
and also we try
uh
samples from
dog
tumors i'm going to refer to the canine
in
the model in a minute
which are actually animals that is
spontaneously developed uh tumors and
you we can see that
they all over express egfr here you see
three tumors one two and three they over
express egfr and
simultaneously they over express also
help you so so we have some post weight
and examples without her2 presence and
when we try the toxin here you can see
again viability and here is depicted
whether we use um
the one
two
the units of units of the tax for
example the first control here on the
left shows a negative addition of the
lfn gta the little factor neither of the
pa of course this gives you 100
variabilities control and the same you
get if you use only one subunit of of
the of the top it's not working both
subunits are required when you use both
subunits in detroit for results you can
see
that in
survivability drops
and it's eliminating all the cells even
when
as you saw in the upper panel here in
this question block t24 express
a help tube mb49 is the same although in
the foreign does not express virtue and
the canadian tumors also
respond very efficiently to the toxic
even when they overexpose capture even a
similar level of egfr
um so
so
in contrast our approach is insensitive
to the presence of culture so this is
great news
um so and as i said we will speculate
that is because the mechanism of
endocytosis
is a microcluster based rather than the
canonical in the pathway of egfr
in addition because of that we have
speculated that some mutants of egfr
which are
resilient for endocytosis inhibited from
will also be able to react to toxins and
that was indeed the case we use a cell
line that we have
mb49le means low egfr
so it has almost doesn't express egfr
and it's a line that we isolated in
in the lab it shows the different egf mu
is or egfr's that we re introducing
itself so
this is the wild type
version of gfr and of course
the survivability now drops this cell
line is resistant to the toxin
so but in the presence of egfr
when transfected back in is sensitive
you can compare
these two
uh
the bars here on the left versus the
ones on the right on the right we have
the line that doesn't express egfr
transfected with each gfp
and it's not sensitive it's not
sensitive to a toxin
but it's transfected with each parabolic
deck it becomes sensitive
so
this is great to show the specificity of
this agent towards the presence of the
receptor
but also our experiments showed
it's listed here which are
either lacking the
acetoplasmic tail either having
mutations that impair the required
phosphorylation events for endocytosis
or
uncapable of forming diamonds it can
also become sensitive to the toxins and
that is because microclustering doesn't
care about the
canonical endocytic pathway
so
another great result was that this toxin
is
extremely fast
and
here you see survivability as a function
of time of exposure to the toxin
and and you can see that even three
minutes is enough to
um
commit the cell swap up process it
doesn't mean that in three minutes the
cells are gone it means that in three
minutes of exposure
in it it will commit the cells to to
undergo a process and we have seen that
if there's a substantial
decrease of cells four hours and eight
hours with maximal disappearance of
cells after 24 hours
so this is great because we can reduce
the treatment time from hours you
remember i told you two to three hours
patients need you
endure treatment two minutes
with this with this agent so so we're
very excited we think it's a
transformative approach
so um
all right so another another area that
we tested was the ability of this toxin
to eliminate cancerous stem cells cancer
stem cells are very important for
recurrence and progression you remember
recurrence is one of the bigger issues
in treatment for bladder cancer
so
we try
our tungsten
against different cancer stem cells of
course we included cancer stem cells
from bladder cancer but also from
prostate lung and even bone marrow
cancer and we have different results
here you see variability again
versus the control and the one
with the presence of the toxin so very
efficient for the elimination of cancer
stem cells from bladder cancer prostate
and lung cancer not so much for bone
marrow cancer and when we look at the
levels of epidemiology receptor at least
in these cancer stem cells we see that
the ability of the toxin to act upon the
of these cells is proportional to the
amount of protein neuropathy receptors
and we also in collaboration with the
department of urology
in the
med school in
iu indianapolis um we tested
the toxin in freshly restricted tumors
from actual human patients
and i call your attention to panel c in
the lower right
part of this
figure in which we can see that the
viability as a function of the toxin
it reaches about 85 percent
for for human symbols
in the other
two panels you can see two pictures of
two patients cells and what you're
seeing is the epidermid reflector
receptor staining and what we saw in
patients is that
for example patients to the left some
cells express a lot for example that one
mark with an asterisk but the others are
expressing medium amounts of epidemio
phytoreceptor and some cells do not
express that much so this pose a problem
right because it suggests that
um
some cells will respond and others will
not
to to the egf toxin in contrast patient
4 is is over expressing the epidermal
factor all throughout all the cells in
the tumor so so this patient is
expected to respond very well to the
toxin so so and that was those results
were um confirmed by flow cytometry as
you can see finally
so this
predicts that some patients will respond
better than others to treatment with
this egfr toxin so to overcome
this problem we are currently
producing several new toxin derivatives
with specificity for other receptors
upregulated in cancer so stay tuned soon
it will come very very exciting to solve
together
we tested this toxin in in vivo and i
remind you the toxin is not added in the
bloodstream we started into the bladder
via the urethra and we tested it in
normal animals in dogs and in mice and
we saw absolutely no toxicity and this
was done by a daily observation physical
examination
with the account for about two months
um i want to remind you that the toxin
is so efficient that it requires
nanomolar concentrations uh while the
intoxication doors for destruction
system the micro mark so so we are
definitely far
from the
toxicity levels of these toxins um
and also this is a binary toxin so
when the toxin is accidentally reaches
the blood stream is dilute each of the
components
making impossible the reconstitution of
the toxic normal cells
so the toxin egf toxin is safe
and
so we treated this uh in vivo then with
using dogs
that
are part of the program of the our
veterinary hospital here at purdue that
has a very successful unit dealing with
transitional cell carcinomas in dogs
that
as i mentioned dogs are prone to develop
liver cancer or very similar
characteristic to human ones and so we
were allowed to treat dogs that
exhausted the relative enough and they
didn't work and they were overpresented
in the molecular factor receptor
so here i'm just showing you one example
so these are
ultrasounds of the bladder
prior to the treatment after the
treatment
you see
the treatment was done for between
and in average out of 12 dogs that we
have treated so far we have seen a 30 to
40 percent reduction in tumor mass this
is huge because the masses of tumors are
huge because as i said these animals
have failed all previous treatments and
they are terminal so the the
four muscles of mass are really really
big
so 30 to 40 percent is a lot of cells
eliminated and the toxin was very well
tolerated it was not toxicity associated
with the treatment
um the current and future direction so
we are moving towards developing other
agents that
will not need
multiple units but the single unit will
be able to
target multiple receptors and even
multiple receptors of different
specificity so um so we envision that we
don't need multiple units like in the
toxin that the name mutually organized
the simulation will be able to clear
such a such a micro cluster and we have
some prototypes that we have created for
this by the way this has been patented
as well just like the toxin and the
microclustering technology and um and
preliminary results with some
prototype shows that it's very very
efficient and very fast
for the update of nanoparticles uh
loaded with a chemical chemotherapy
and then we are expanding to other kind
of cancers so far for um
for application of this technique
so
just a very brief summary and i will end
with this
the microconstraint technique have been
developed to induce the uptake of
therapeutic by bladder cancer cells but
now we think it can be exposed to other
type of cancers
we have three generations of agents
on that have been successful and i'm
very excited about these developments
and i will just
acknowledge my collaborators on these
projects uh
dr kim bradley and debbie knapp in the
purview center for cancer research
which were really very instrumental for
the development of these
approaches and the use in mice and in
dogs but also doctors michael [ __ ] and
mr camacliotis in the department of
urology of the iu school of medicine
and in the initial phases of this
project
john collier and then brad pentelot
from harvard and mit
contributed for the purification and
production of this program and actually
the initial
toxin was designed by john carter
and with that i will just acknowledge in
my my laboratory
particularly
brian kuhn which was involved in the
development of the micro clustering
technique shared with jack that was
involved in the development of the toxin
approach along now with neha suramanian
and andres aries and of course
we
acknowledge our sources of fund in
particular the national
here and with that
thank you for your attention